We have updates tonight on the DOJ
investigation into Donald Trump.
And there's new ludicrous things
that the congresswoman from Geor
is saying about January 6th
and how much worse it would have
if she'd been in charge.
Somehow she's proud of that.
But it's deeper than just
hateful comments.
That congresswoman
is on the verge of being placed
on important committees
and having real power.
Plus, shocking
happens tonight
almost seven months after the ho
tragic Eumundi School shooting.
We're learning tonight
the sheriff's department
actually had no active
shooter policy
when 19 children
and two of their teachers
were shot to death in their clas
How could they protect these kid
If there was never a plan?
Okay, so we have a lot to talk a
Let's bring in CNN's John Berman
We also have with us senior lega
Ellie Hoenig and former
Republican Congressman Charlie D
Gentlemen, great to have you all
So let's start with the updates
in what's going on
with now the special counsel's
investigation into all things
Donald Trump.
They want to interview
Brad Raffensperger,
secretary of state in Georgia.
That makes sense. He is a pivota
Why hasn't the DOJ interviewed h
It's been almost two years.
Can I answer your question
with just the word amen?
I mean, I asked the same questio
Why has it taken so long?
And look, this is a failure.
It's not going to doom the case.
But it's an unforced error
by prosecutors.
Let me explain why.
Laura knows this.
As a prosecutor,
you guard your witnesses jealous
If you get wind
that you have someone
who you think is an important wi
and someone else
is poking around another agency,
another prosecutor's office,
you shut them down
and you keep your witness away.
Now, why is it because of greed?
No, it's
because you don't want
your witnesses exposed.
So let's look at Brad Raffensper
We know he's testified
in front of the January six comm
There's a book on him, literally
There's a transcript full
of his testimony
and what's going to happen
if he becomes a DOJ witness.
The defense
lawyers are going
to get all that material.
They're entitled to it
and they're going to pick them a
Oh, you said it
a little differently
this time than that time.
Oh, let's follow up on this.
And so the more of a record
there is on your witness,
the more vulnerable he is.
And so DOJ,
they're talking to Brad Raffensp
almost two years out. Great.
But they're too late.
And it's really,
frankly, embarrassing
that they were beaten to the pun
by a congressional committee,
of all things.
It gives me pause as well on tha
because you think about the idea
There's also he's written a book
I mean, he's written it,
so anything
may be different from that, etc.
But also
we're talking about a special co
having now been appointed.
And so I have to wonder
what were the other prosecutors
until this point in time?
I mean, the idea of
and maybe we're not privy to eve
I will give the benefit of the d
in many respects.
However, why now Why is
are we just getting around to it
a few days before this committee
is going to be good night? It.
Yeah, it's a good question.
And by the way, this is not a on
Cassidy Hutchinson.
Right. Right.
Remember, when she testified,
I mean, she blew the roof off
and it turned out the reporting
from The New York Times at the t
DOJ was totally caught by surpri
Why? Because they're moving too
Because they spent a year and ch
Look, they had to do these.
80,900 prosecutions of the peopl
stormed the Capitol. No doubt.
The problem was during that time
they focused exclusively on thos
and not on the key witnesses.
Now they're getting there now.
They've been much more aggressiv
the last four to six months,
which is good.
But there's a cost for being slo
But to be fair on this point, yo
the committee was not forthcomin
always with information, right?
I mean, you're rolling your eyes
but the up.
But they also were
having to fight
a little bit about who would giv
what information when.
But, you know, the committee,
their role is not prosecutorial.
Their role is to have oversight,
to try to correct
some shortcomings of the law, et
Do you see the idea of the commi
moving quickly and moving slowly
We're
you have reports to
the Brad Raffensperger thing.
You don't need the committee.
Yeah.
You know,
the only people who knew about t
call was everybody
like the world
planet Earth knew about that pho
So either DOJ looked at it and d
there was nothing there
or they were just slow
walking it for two years,
which is hard to understand.
The flip side of this,
I will say there's two things.
Other things about this
which jump out to me number one,
the Raffensperger recall deals
with illegality
involved possible illegality
of only one person in one.
Personally, this me
and this is Donald Trump.
I mean, you talk to Raffensperge
if you're investigating Donald T
exclusively to see if he broke a
The other thing is
they did talk to the White House
lawyers last week. Right. That's
So as weird
as this is, as weird and late
as this all seems,
the fact that they broke down th
and we're talking to White House
and broke through that privilege
that's a big deal.